allez on se retrouve pour finir donc la
série sur sur la bourdonnais est donc
une dernière partie il a les blancs
contre quelqu'un s'appelle l'écrivain
parce que c'était son vrai nom est ce
que ce que c'était son métier d'être
écrivain je sais pas tout casser une
partie qui s'est jouée ou café de la
régence en 1837 seulement donc quelques
années avant avant la mort donc de la
bourdonnais dont je crois qui est mort
en 1840 et allez c'est parti
alors ils allaient blanc dans notre ami
d'abord donné aux 4,6 et f4 donc qui
jouent comme comme son rival à l'époque
o'donnell f4 sur la française et 5,5
ces cinq et ils cherchent donc à créer
le gros centre d'un v6 food et 3 donc
bon pourquoi pas à vrai dire le fou va
se replacer ensuite versé 2 et on pourra
faire un des quatre quand même et rauque
est l'aliment ont fait à six bon je suis
pas fan je pense un bon que ça
absolument à rien j'aurais préféré voir
un coût de développement poussé deux
fous 17 des quatre reprises prise fougue
et quatre échecs
ma foi pourquoi pas k et ses trois
quarts et g7 petit rock et donc est mort
il fait petit rock et là je vous pose
une question qu'est-ce que vous jouez
parce que évidemment je pense qu'on
s'est tous les idées avec vos proches
sept qui sont thématiques dans leur
position la question c'est est ce que ça
marche
est-ce que ça gagne voilà donc
réfléchissez mes tempes aux français un
bon exercice de
voilà parce que est ce que ça marche
toujours est ce qu'il ya des méthodes de
défense
donc à vous de voir à noter dans la
partie d'abord de nage de fourrage 7 bon
bah j'espère vous a mis en pause vous
avez calculé vous êtes votre avis et je
vais vous dire fou prend âge sa taille
ici est une faute
d'où te dire que ça ne va pas donner vie
en blanc et on va y revenir suez et je
vous expliquerai pourquoi le mieux dans
cette position mon avis c'est de faire
simplement à 3 est-ce que ce fou ne peut
pas reculer évidemment veut l'enfermer
donc il doit prendre si on prend du coup
les blancs défendre leurs pions des 4 et
les normes plus vendre contre jeu
maintenant les bancs complètement les
mains libres pour aller attaquer les
noirs donc la foux prend h7 sort elle
mène à cette fois ci avec kg 5
la dame qui vient de dieu on pourra
aussi parfois faire juste du cac et g5
la torre un gars f3 g3 ou h3 essayer de
faire marcher 5 à bonne escient bref
c'est juste une pression de rêve pour
les blancs avec une attaque dévastatrice
mais on va regarder ce qui se passe dans
la partie regrouperait en un seul
trois princes est donc on a eu l'idée
c'est qu'ils agissent 5 et maintenant
les noirs ont deux choix soit faire
roger 8 soit faire
roy g6 et je veux dire que les deux
peuvent défendre même si le cookie les
leurs au g8 dans la partie et pas mal
mais qu'est ce qui se passe en général
ce roi g6 en fait en général les blancs
gagne en jouant dame g4s qu'on se
demande vis-à-vis du roi on va de masse
et des découvertes à droite à gauche et
droit soit sermat et son va avoir de
lourdes pertes matérielles mais ici dams
et 4 c'est juste une faute
j'espère vous avez vu et c'était
l'objectif de l'exercice que je vous
disais de calcul à un faux prince est
alors pourquoi pas ce qu'il ya dedans me
prendrait quatre échecs roi bon bah on
va le mettre en achat on va dire et
maintenant qu'ils avaient les premiers
signes forts coûts parce que y'a clouage
ici et est donc les noirs arrivent à
défendre en fait ce genre de positions
pariant sur un peu comme d'alger 3 pour
rester dans le vis-à-vis avec le roi
mayaki aliev 5 et du coup les plantes se
font repousser et ils ont investi une
pièce pour rien par mika et détroit et
puis bon ok le rejet si c'est un peu en
dehors de ces abris mais qu'ils
attaquent en fait là les noirs ou une
pièce de plus et option et c'est juste
un carnage comme donc après un orage et
six dames g4 et le coup classique pour
attaquer marche pas deuxièmement ce que
veulent faire les noirs s'est vite et 6
pour chasser ce cavalier et pouvoir
retourner se se mettre à l'abri dans
leurs terriers par l'ensemble kung fu et
3 on se dira oui je voudrais faire
d'alger quatre ans huit mamans qui a
plus d'homme prendre quatre eh ben la
voilà f6 serait pas mal comme ça avec
les noirs où on repousse le cavalier on
peut aller se cacher du coup ici la
meilleure option pour le manceau arrêté
de jouer à fond pour ouvrir la ligne
avec f5 paraît donc amélie prend et on
ramène ce cavalier à eux deux est ok ça
donnait quand même une position pas
hyper clair là je me la rente que
j'avais analysé
vous voyez ça c'est compliqué mais au
final si on compte les pièces bon les
noms comme qui était plus
après c'est quand même pas claire parce
que dans la position qu'on obtient là
les blancs ou un bon blocus sur case
noire et tout reste à faire mais en tout
cas ça ne gagne pas disons voilà c'est
une partie c'est juste des compensations
voilà après bon cheval est un peu vite
su s'y intéresse peut être même je peux
revenir en détail sur sur la variante
parce que quand je vous disais f5
qu'avaient les prends ça avec qui on
prendra telle option
mais comme vous l'avez découvert en
lente l'idée c'était que turcs avaient
lieu deux ex cavalli qui ne vérifie 4 et
c'est un problème sa préquelle f4 roi
prend g5 et damages cinq matches donc ça
serait assez mauvais pour les noirs en
fait je dois dire faut absolument
prendre du cavalier qui avaient lieu
deux c'était l'idée on allait lucille
cailly prend le 5e tout à l'heure avec
les clous âge c'était dans ce sens
maintenant c'est dans ce sens toujours
des histoires de clouage et l'idée aussi
de prendre 5 c'est sûr qu'avec quatre au
moins le roi noir peu fier et plus et se
réfugier vers le centre et donc tout
reprendre sans excès telle idée
le problème c'est que sur fion prend
cavaliers f4 voilà il ya une fourchette
voilà ce qu'explique la variante est
donc si on rapproche f5 et bats la rente
que je vous montre sp celle là pour
attendre de s'enfuir ont fait d'amener
on va les mater là bas j'ai 610 vite qui
avait pris 9 7 sacrifices
bien sûr on peut pas prendre pourquoi
parce que les blancs veut faire une
découverte à ce moment là ils ont
déblayé les débats allant dans ce
cavalier est allé récupérer la dame bon
croiser cet écueil points 5 pour
n'obtiendrait ce genre de choses mais
voilà déjà c'était disons important de
comprendre sera g6 d'objets 4 ne
suffisaient pas à gagner et pas mal donc
l'idée du f 5-2 pour continuer attaque
côté blanc mais qui ne gagnait pas bon
maintenant on va revenir à la partie
laférois g8 ont du coup ce qu'on aime
faire avec les lampes continue l attaque
c'est classique ces dames h5 et ça c'est
un gain systématique si énorme peuvent
pas défendre cette bon dans la partie il
a mal défendu la fetwa ses huit pour
essayer de courir avec le roi sont
réfugiés sur les ailes dames et ça va
perdre mais est-ce que c'est est il
impossible que ça défend de cette
diagonale
en fait non on pourrait faire d'un
prendrait quatre échecs
lisons tous rêvent de qui est mieux
jouer croire h1 pourquoi parce que dans
les deux cas toute façon les noirs
veulent jouer dans le détroit
donc on comprend ce pour défendre cette
case mais là en plus il gagne un temps
sur la tour ce qui est problématique en
fait pour les plantes
ils vont manqué d'allant pour continuer
leurs attaques et donc c'est mieux de
faire de faire 3 2 parce que maintenant
chose importante dam des trois marchent
pas bien
5 on bloque la dame et voilà face à la
différence du coup ici il aurait fallu
s'en aller avec la torah secousse ce
coup-ci sur dame 3,7 faire vos achats
suite
et à vrai dire les blancs ou pas mieux
que de répéter les coups parce qu'ils
ont que le duo dame cavalli pour
l'attack tour peut pas venir se joindre
ici et et noir sont justes à
à un coût de ramener la dame la défense
ou de mettre un cavalier qui va tenir
tout bloquer et c est ici mais il
fallait se faire d'un meurtre cinq des
neuf cet échec échec
bon maintenant regarder la partie ce qui
s'est passé parce que il a fait preuve
ces huit ont pesé ruiz dame prend des
quatre pour atout voir arriver tôt ou
tard bah oui et non parce qu'après d'un
problème ça trois fuites
bon là il n'a pas joué de la manière la
plus précise mais ça gagne aussi ce
qu'il a fait il ya vait touareg 3 et sur
dame prend des cas on va simplement des
hongrois agen et boé quoi faire contre
une torche 3 c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas
de maths du couloir et le colis qui
défend et la tour est libre thaler a été
clouée dans la même position qu'on a vu
et ça change tout toujours un petit
orgue de cookies changer voilà donc là
les noirs s'ils cherchent à akoupé bien
sûr l'échec ici on va juste mater de
cette manière là donc sera à suivre ton
rêve 3 était simple et efficace mais il
a plutôt joué comme ça la bourdonnais
roigé 827 rapide de mach 8 kg vite et
échecs bon il a répété une fois des
coûts et f5 en quelque sorte bien joué
parce qu'il veut faire participer la
tour à la table du roi et on retrouve
une fois de plus ce principe quand on
attaque le roy on ouvre les lignes c'est
un truc fort a toujours gardé en tête
quand je vois des parties d'attac faut
viser le roi et donc vos pièces puissent
participer attaque donc là on avoir la
tour et peut-être aussi ouvrir le fou
qui peut arriver et donner un coup de
main à un moment donné alors là le
problème pour les noirs c'est donc s'ils
prennent on va continuer par six donc on
attaque ce fou et on veut faire 3.5 au
suivant et il n'y a pas vraiment de quoi
lutter avec aimar si on prend ce pion ce
sont les fils de m leroy la breizh
machin et des problèmes restent
exactement les mêmes ok alors sur les
100 et qu'il a tenté de fuir et croix de
cette dame francs g7 aura des 8 puis on
prend bon là le problème c'est qu'on
menace
me prend 17 matchs et puis la tour peut
venir participer au jeu il ya qui a valu
en l'air enfin y en ait un peu de
partout
alors ils ont fait ça pour un peu sauver
le roi tandis possible mais la belle
suite trouvé par parle à bord donna qui
trouve un match quelque part tour f 8
passes et 7 cavalli prend des cinq donc
local étant prise mais le problème c'est
que le call you 7 servait à couper la
septième rangée maintenant dame prend 17
points et vite
dames france limite pour à cet homme
prend 8 échec et mat
donc finalement belle attaque qui part
d'un sacrifice thématique de fou prend
1,7 mais j'ai choisi cet exemple pour
mettre en garde c'est pas un coût qui
gagnera toujours faut bien vous vérifiez
sotra certes peut ramener une pièce et
défendent cette diagonale et défendre ce
math ici alors ça c'est une méthode de
défense classique et aussi quand le
montre le roi pour tanger si c'est ce
que dame g4 est possible ou pas voilà
donc on a vu des petits schémas
d'attaqué intéressant et donc voilà on a
fini avec avec la bourdonnais dont qui
était vraiment le meilleur joueur
dans les années entre 1800 et 1840 sont
pas des 800 juste de m 1820 on va dire
et donc qui a marqué l'histoire des
échecs et donc des échecs français bien
sûr qu'ils qui est un très bon joueur
d'attac mais aussi qu' on a vu dans
l'ouverture qui est un bon feeling et
donc qui a donné son nom à ces mandats
signés de la kalachnikov et qui a fait
de bonnes parties j'espère vous avez
bien aimé et puis on se retrouvera à
bientôt pour avancer en veillant
d'autres joueurs français qui ont marqué
l'histoire il y en a eu la même lui qui
ont été champions du monde
donc voilà on voit aussi gentiment à
travers l'histoire et les époques
allez savoir